welcome back to true news true news oh
it's been a while
we'd be busy we had a lot of [__] gone
off our chests not literally and as some
of you may know 2020 is the year that
you're truly looks to secure the bug
look after himself look after us yeah
but first a word from our sponsors well
that was gracious no Bryant rage shadow
legs what was what I was getting to oh
you weren't you would talk about
yourself again raid want you to tell
them all about the game yes that's what
I'm talking about so red shadow ledger
Wow again what how have looked after the
lads you guys need to look after them as
well that's the point
no that's what we need you guys to do we
need this is our webs you love our
content they love our content we love
their game yeah you're gonna love their
game as well you need you know what you
need to do you need to download this
game like we did at support read shuttle
legend but first a word from our
sponsors raid shadow legend those folks
my favorite bit of the ad you know when
they go but first and then is other
memes and I'm not just saying this
because it's sponsorship this is the
best-looking more belk am not ever plead
it looks like a trip you're on a console
like the current as you play on like
those corny little childish cartoon
characters that you usually go I mean
even fortnight that's got that sort of
like this is console level like it looks
beautiful you can also have like
different flavors however mood you're in
so or if you're if you're a girl you can
play like a warrior princess type [__]
or if you're a dude you get these big
[__] this guy who looks kinda like me
like [__] and then there's the dragon
and then there's whatever flavor you're
in they got you covered you yeah and I
like upgrading as well as you do
throughout the game so you're just
building your character up and as you go
through each battle you become more
prepared each time you kick ass yeah I
do I do like kicking ass let me just
show a little bit of gameplay here
there's always like PvP battles and
stuff but look what I can do boom boom
dead gone get out
loser and just like that bang riding the
equipment this helmet don't which other
games you had were you're like reading
things in your voices and stuff like
that okay so we're back at the back of
the course or time to kill bang bang
you're going down mate demoralizing
display is actually something quite
satisfying about this because you do
something and sometimes there's a mobile
game you're a bit like yeah yeah and you
see the animation
the animation on this is really good one
thing that is good about this game is
when you get stopped which you do on
every [__] game yeah you got a
community online where you just jump on
YouTube search a bit like you're in
you'll get the answer you'll get the
tips yeah and you're a part of something
with this game oh yeah and you can see
all those other people as a community
online I do like that and here's the
thing Brian I know a lot of people play
on the way to work but if you're at work
you a little bit bored at home yeah it's
one of those things it's now
cross-device so you can basically take
it onto your desktop as well good save
here play here yeah as the same user
yeah so if you're going further in the
game yeah you just put it back on your
mobile boom okay so now you know about
the game if you didn't the last few
times yeah a lot of users said recently
you want to support us you want to help
us out well I'm calling in the favor
lads if you could click the link in the
description below and download this game
have a good play on it it's [__] free
yeah you know I'm not asking much come
on I'm asking you buy anything like I'm
a youtuber just play a free game for us
and I think you'll enjoy it anyway there
are special links down there in the
description and if you guys click those
make sure you had a hundred thousand
silver one free any to refill 50 gems
and one free champion this guy's for the
executioner yeah cool as [__] me either
is one of my favorites eventually
playing the water beams or channeling my
inner executioner it's quite profound I
lived through him vicariously yeah
obviously and that's why I enjoy the
game so much I need a cell phone or
mobile all the treasure will be waiting
for you here apparently though those
rewards are only relevant for 30 days so
you got you got to do it now it's no
good coming back to a layer like we need
you to download it yeah thank you
Cheers mmm press play on the video
Rachel
[Music]
I always said we probably ended on the
last one but they've done it they've
done it again youtubers have made me
care who wins as they punch each other
yeah I just can't help it loads I
thought who gives a [__] they're all
[__] boxes anyway but guess what they're
good at doing that right make me care
right you know me now you're a caring
guy though very giving there's a story
like that's the problem right you know
like Star Wars had a story live until
they have tiller ruined it miss noir but
like you mean there's a storyline that's
well you look at Gable it's like if ever
Miran it's not really cared about the
fact that he was on the first card you
know he starts gathering some momentum
he beats Jace ringa no junior angler in
relative to YouTube audiences his big
yeah big guy he's also a tough
[__] took some butchers nothing
like I think it's fair to say put on the
most entertaining fight we've seen on
YouTube ever we never thought you would
get a big fight cuz he showed he could
box he showed it made sure he could
fight we never thought anyone would give
him that opportunity because he wasn't a
big youtuber Jake Paul on the other hand
he was turning down the Jay Jay fight
initially I don't need this boxing you
ksi you need this I don't need this
because at the time let's all forget for
Jake Paul was bringing in major views
yeah I think he might have even doing
big I've used in JJ once upon a time so
he was like you know all you need this I
don't need this and then the script is
being flipped so much like JJ now is one
of the biggest guys Jake his views have
clearly gone down I know he's taken
breaks and whatever but ultimately like
I said on the podcast to him the content
has just gone in a different direction
and people aren't liking it as much
anymore people just don't like him as
much as they did once upon a time as
much of a villain in a platform way how
much people like you decides on whether
or not they watch you it hurts your
brand when people think you're a bit of
an [__] I kind of like the fact that
he's gone that way but not everyone does
we don't know why I like the one people
like like a bit of a dick sometimes I
mean it's funny Jake 10 beats 10 G
monster KS I fight to avenge his brother
Logan he can't get it JT aside at the
top of the mountain like I've done this
I don't need this anymore I don't need
you now so Jake thinks the only way I
can get this fight is of our beat give
all up are then beating his brother and
his best mate or one of his good friends
and then I call him out that's the goal
for me I know that is the goal I
on him I make it impossible to avoid the
fight okay i Kerrigan caused himself
7-figure gibbehh
this could be his path to seven figures
he'll owe six
he's the Rocky of YouTube boxing he
isn't the one everyone thought was the
charm of the biggest name but he's
becoming the people's even he's going
well I love the fact that gibble as even
saying I finessed you into this so you
have no idea I've almost conned you into
taking this fight and now you're in deep
[__] I like the attitude training hard
the size difference is quite a bit
gibble got balls so one of the main
things is that gibble has recently been
beating Jake Paul in the views which is
mental because Jake's obviously 20
million subs Gibble's when he just hit
two million yeah like the whole thing
was Jake taught mocking Gabe or who is
this guy who the [__] is he
and it's like he's out doing him in
there because the UK who got behind give
up there they love this guy now she's
gonna look at the press conference I'm
excited to put on a good show you know
we've been putting in the work training
our asses off in Big Bear with the with
the legend right here it's an honor to
be working with him interestingly Jake
Paul has taken Sugar Shane Mosley as his
coach as he calls him when Shannon
Briggs came in bit of a joke yadi yadi
like alright he had the titles but
people still found him to be an idiot do
you think when they sacked him they went
alright let's go champ well it feels
like Jay Paul's sucked him almost the
night of the fight was like I'm not
getting trained by you anymore possible
when he was busy squeezing ice all over
his eyes yeah this is the thing he's
gone do an actual boxing legend now
Sugar Shane Mosley is not like you know
let's go chump type [__] like this guy
is going to teach you how to box and
he's one of the only people that lay a
glove on Floyd Mayweather so you know
like he knows some [__] badal still
undefeated yeah as a boxing coach has
said this is his final time coaching a
youtuber where are your 20 million
followers now no way you've got your
goons up there just not made more money
off your name than them saying yes for
the rest of their lives
that's a
really good light he called them Gucci
as in an interview which I found
hilarious that was actually in the title
of an interview with him it's mental
right for me I've said this a couple
times before I need to say this when I
first met this kid he was a chubby lad
sat next to me at the one buddy cop who
had wasn't high on confidence a
personality yes he would never have
gotten her face of a kid who looked like
Jake Paul at that point the
transformation gives one do is [__]
phenomenal good on him I know everyone
thinks I picked myself up or some [__]
like that pretty much yeah this needed
don't say this guy's this guy's dead
not literally no but yeah [__] me how
prepared are you to enter the ring
against Jake Paul it's not the best
question is it yeah
cousin give me a call we sought the so
also though what's he gonna do he's
gonna go actually I'm not prepared at
all I'm [__] myself no she brought
Morgan listen than you you got out
worked by gee do you think daddy ever
sits at home and just goes the dogs dead
like that you know the dog isn't I don't
know if the talks dead yes you could ask
you know he got killed
yeah that's not fun you know they
threatened to send his mother in prison
yeah have you seen the attack it's more
of a barking at I must admit I was I was
shocked at that because when I heard
that this was it in our session yeah
it's a big dog to be fair our stations a
scary dog
yeah they look a bit like [__] mate I
could probably bite your face off a
German Shepherd some all right whatever
it ran up the woman but then didn't
really do much to her I'm like you've
done your job like that yeah it's
supposed to scare off intruders he
thought this was an intruder yeah like I
was half-expecting because of the fact
that it's getting put down at this to
turn into a [__] bleeding or like
really bad oh yeah it was not bad yeah
we didn't even I don't I don't know well
this he definitely bit our at some point
because that's the report but like it
must have been a very like an it yeah
yeah you know I mean nothing else off so
save tongue that's what I'm saying
dead geez reaction got more views than
Jake Paul's up third day geez just
playing Fifa I'm just watching the same
video he just sees that big [__] nose
when he wakes up in the morning that's
his [__] views do you want to talk
about views suck my
just to be clear dead you know comment
videos comment round three you lost your
conditioning out of breath Big Bear
ain't gonna save you can I just say Big
Bear will have an impact by the way Tito
Ortiz trained for years up in Big Bear
because basically at high altitude your
body is operating with a lot less oxygen
so when you come down to regular level
you're amazing it's unbelievable well
you're going to find it a lot easier to
keep going and going and going as your
body as you stop everything under a lot
of stress have you ever felt very gonna
save you have you ever fought
three-minute rounds yes of course now
you have your last fight was moving
around yeah I sparred last fight was for
gonna ride round three the gibble paces
is almost of youtube legend at this
point as output is high more and more
than anyone yeah maybe
JJ's update as well but like very high
to do that in two-minute rounds is a lot
easier than a three wow that's just my
mathematical opinion no no no no no no
stop make some videos your youtubers oh
[__] me there's only one person I think
would I would be interested in a fight
between with Deji and that'll be Joella
I think size-wise
okay so following rise I'd seen Joe when
he was out there was it Johnny Nelson
off at the Train aim and there's a fire
still enjoy that was clear just to get
back in there one time Deji is obviously
quite good with his hands actually he
wasn't bad he was just not fit enough
that was that would be a good one you
could you could barely be a kid who is
the same size as you I'm bigger faster
stronger better looking than you know it
is gonna be interesting
cuz Jess wingler has got the heart of a
lion but a boxer he is not
Jake Paul is a much better boxer than
Jay and Jay did Koch give over time so
he's gonna have to have improved his
defense at least to win this fight the
reason I'm interested in this more than
any other is because Jake Paul has very
little the game and almost everything to
lose he is risking a lot just to get
this fight with Jay Jay Jay if he loses
the gibble who is the smaller guy in
terms of physical but all
so in terms of youtube i am i'll give
all husband estimates he's actually
telling the truth he said he has hunted
him down and forced this fight on him
because no one else would do it and jake
has seen an opportunity to get in the
ring with Jay Jay but he's risking a lot
against the dangerous guy who's gonna
come at him a hundred mile an hour and
throw everything on the kitchen sink
Gibble's already won by even get in this
fight his profiles gone up as
subscribers have gone up he's gonna make
a [__] ton of money this is fantastic
a bit like that G like you win just by
stepping in the ring with Jake because
Jake is not a loved personality right
people outside of his farm base if you
do anything to him you're a hero if you
beat him you're your legendary I mean
the calm up from where he was to where
he could be if he wins that fight is God
I don't know if anyone's don't know it's
the biggest ride yeah and one of the
biggest drivers we've ever seen yeah cuz
everyone else was fighting across it's
unlikely hero punch yeah it's an
absolute unlikely hero and I love him
for the fact that he's just going on it
[__] it let's do this especially against
a bigger guy you got a thing for Jake to
get in the ring with him and risk
everything he's risking for such a
little game just to get a fight with Jay
Jay potentially yeah he has to have
major self belief as well he has nothing
like his chances I'm doing this and I'm
winning guaranteed he must feel that way
the whole world is probably gonna be on
gibble side I've got to say I've got
imagine everyone's gonna be the outside
of the Jake poor farm is everyone's
gonna be like if he does this scenes
yeah on the other hand if Jake Paul wins
in devastating fashion grabs the mic and
calls out Jay Jay I've always felt from
day one that Logan and JJ yeah the the
rivalry was real but the real hit was
Jake and Jay Jay they read from the
videos they [__] hate each other that
would be the only fight that could
really get invested in again like fully
like the way we were over Logan and Jay
Jay I think that would be because
they're almost like two bad guys yeah
going against each other and then we can
finish YouTube box it probably brilliant
I've gotta say okay it's gotta be the
last whatever calls it to an end
whatever sort of puts the bullet in its
head I'm good for it do you know what I
mean I think this fight might be the
best youtuber fight yet I think we're
getting to know and I'm not just saying
that on the eddy her internals closed
all that crap like they're not gonna
play it safe I feel like with JJ and
Logan there was so much on the line
there was so much hype around it
I mean JJ definitely went for it but
Logan was a bit more cautious and I just
feel like these two Jake and gibble then
there's no mercy there they're going now
all out yeah I think we're getting a
knock now and I think we'll have a
decisive win and it's gonna be an
exciting fight I'm actually gonna really
enjoy this yeah I'll do my prediction
video later in the month but let us know
who you think is gonna win in the
comments this is one of my favorite
interviews I've ever seen in my life
I was really hoping it was gonna be the
Queen why is this funny favorite
interview where is this Miami yeah how
do women yeah have tiny waist but
massive asses like that you don't see
that in England I've never seen a woman
like that in English is that the only
reason you wanted me to watch this video
yeah I just seen it and thought wow you
shell oh man I'm not I'm just admiring I
just love opera guards nothing wrong
with admiring a female body I think she
probably regrets standing in the
background of that interview she doesn't
speaking of fighting coming up soon on
the Truvada youtube channel we're doing
a live stream for the Conor McGregor
comeback fight are we covered this story
a while back and it's since come out
that Conor McGregor I repeat is not the
father who's got his first winner there
Gregory arrest yeah I've had mixed
opinions of Connor in the last few years
but at least he didn't father a child
with this woman she was convinced you
tell everyone who would listen is his
daddy yeah it wasn't he just probably
shagged the DNA test confirmed that the
31 year old mixed martial arts star was
not the father he is considering
defamation proceedings anything against
it news outlets who reported the
allegations I think that's great
I mean we report it long after everyone
else got wind of it we weren't the first
do you know mean so if Connor because I
haven't got any money anyway bro good
Lots
yeah good luck with the fight hope you
do well cheering yawn yeah you've
already won round one although I've
heard Connor can go many rounds if you
know what I mean yeah not a great look
for a married man in a club though is it
ever like yeah not great I mean he
probably pulled out and buffs all over
our face I shouldn't have said that
why don't we ever go to red carpets I
would hear that sound next to each other
and go the fact no one wants to see it's
a log and Paul this is some guy who
played in the NFL and Tony a brand now
you're an NFL fire master you don't know
anything about this Antonio Brown has a
dodgy history which is why he's
currently not on a team so what what is
that history it involves aggression
towards certain people women there's an
element who else you can't make
accusations is not technically legal
just mean the guys were gonna sue let me
fight look let's put this way right this
guy came to train last summer in Europe
right he did like cold treatment on his
legs didn't put any protection on them
gave himself like first degree burns on
his feet first day went to practice
guess what he took to practice what
vehicle would you think what craft would
you take to your first practice with a
team that's right Brian hot-air balloon
he's the Nile Ranger of the NFL yeah
there was a doctor a previous team who
treated him and he said when he was
treating Antonio Antonio Brown thought
was funny to spot like when he was
around his ass too far in his face
that's the kind of guy we're dealing
with here the one thing I do know about
the NFL is athletically speaking we're
talking the creme de la creme then we're
talking silly like elite level what it
takes to get in the NFL you have to be a
beast
logan's a good boxer at AU - boxer level
we've seen he's one of the better guys
do you not I mean him and Jay Jay like
really took it with a solid level but
there are levels to athleticism I think
one of the reasons that makes logon good
is because he is such a good athlete and
I love this kid like he's a a great guy
but he's not on the level of this guy
clearly as an athlete I haven't even
seen him but the fact that he's in the
NFL we're talking the different beasts
we're not talking state wrestling this
is Antonio Brown this guy is crazy
all right don't fight an NFL player
anyway don't fight a crazy NFL my rule
yeah always assume always the same never
fight someone who'd fought in your face
yeah the chances are he's going to get
in there and [__] people off this guy's
clinging on to a career and relevance
right now don't fight someone who's a
desperate desperate yeah desperate we're
seeing although you tubers get in a new
I think there was rumor of gmx one in
the fight Logan
size-wise skill wise that would be a
really interesting fight you know what I
mean
do anything for fame what's the point of
this I never did that when I had a
McLaren just saying
World War three Porsche wasn't it when
the government comes knocking on my door
for the draft all right three smart dog
good a really good way you would hope
that if that happens Engel rights will
come into effect city women should be
able to fight in wars if they do what
they I'm not getting anything if it's a
draft it should have no choice yeah
exactly and if anything walk out of
London yard if we're gonna be in any of
the cause I'd like to join the media
core thank you blue hats press yeah
absolutely certain this guy journalist
yeah you know least journalist I'm asked
if you had these and a3x early favorited
my reply really catchy Vishal slide min
the dams feel like Alex's package yeah
look at this chopper Wow currently was
singing along to a rap song and someone
caught him drop in the n-bomb he's on
safari this was not even look there was
an M Bob near that you did see the mouse
even if he did because it was a James
Charles is over polity all over Twitter
and all that [__] it's poorly thought
out and he know maybe you shouldn't do
it yeah but I don't think he's actually
walking around calling people like it
was one of those moments where he was
just singing the song and yes bit drunk
he's had a couple of mojitos with his
friends party yeah I'm not pro him
saying it didn't come against it as a
mistake it's an understandable one if
he's drunk in a club at 2:00 a.m. drink
like whatever yeah I don't know I guess
my only point about him dropping the N
bomb during a song is like does that
make him racist he probably also sings
along to [__] all the [__] as well
he's not [__] all the [__] I think
we probably just let them if you're a
woman in the comments just let us know
would you have sex with James Charles
like just for the novelty [__] it just
the klamath a chick with a dick as they
say yeah just to claim it and go change
Charles McMahon to a t-shirt hurry and
Megan the Royals basically said we're
out we'll love what you do with the
royal family not for us yeah we'll see
you later we're off to America nice
was great but yeah thanks for all the
money hell don't associate with pedals
yeah as what this and the Queen looked
up from her baby dinner said what yeah
yeah just a face full of flesh yeah have
you got any theories on why the oh yeah
if I had a pedophile in my family I'd
also love to distract from it do you
think that this is why this has been
announced right now should the police
arrest Prince Andrew or should everyone
why would you arrest someone he's a
perfectly normal guy who just enjoys a
piece to express every now and again oh
no should we we've all been when hurry
and Megan found each other and he was
like this is the one I think he went to
the royal family on this family we need
on the side are not living in 2020
mentally they're in the foot and 1,500
right these people genuinely believe
that God chose them yet they believe
they've got royal blood we all like the
make there might seem like normal people
it like a lot of the old Paul Dee's who
still believe in this [__] yeah like
the thing that they're not they're not
normal that they genuinely don't act
normal Princess Diana dying when she did
wasn't normal generally she was [__]
outside the blood line she was going
with foreigners you know what I mean and
ultimately to them in my opinion this is
what Harry Stoney's brought a girl who's
a mixed-race girl it's a family event
this is the one I want to marry and
they've won to him before I need this
even Hubbard if this is what you're
gonna do you're leaving the royal family
your this is you're out yeah this is
your punishment if this is what you want
to do enough you weren't even properly
related to us well I think that this is
part of it though I think that they have
said before all of the marriage happen
all the way to happen they went if you
choose her you're gone so they've gone
through the process and now it's like
hubs are being long enough with Andrew
Peter scandal all right now's the time
eject trouble the thing yeah I mean yeah
I think that this has all been pre
agreed for it because they're a bunch of
racists my opinion Piers Morgan has been
just [__] and so much about Harry and
Megan like he hates we get it his mixed
rice the level of tweets about this yeah
compared to what he said about Prince
Andrew though the way he was so careful
about what he said about Prince Andrew
you've got a match what's going on now
your reaction
Prince Andrew it's not a convicted black
man though Prince Harry did a little bit
of an interview while black people have
resurfaced this and you can see why
because it's sort of alludes to the fact
that what he was going to do the whole
time
my mum clearly told me a certain set of
values and if anybody else knew what I
knew bit of father being a husband in
anyone you do she probably do be doing
exactly what I'm doing as well what does
he know does he mean towards Megan Marco
I think not not Diana I think he's
leaving that wide open for good reason
he's a very smart guy clearly the way he
spoke was very open-ended I respect this
guy hugely if you ever left the comfort
of being in the royal family to go out
there and not fend for yourself but
basically make things almost actively
more difficult for yourself I think what
he wants to do is be left to [__] along
I mean he's opting out of all of this
bollocks and and I think that getting
the missus is giving him the courage to
go you know what it is I'd rather just
be with you and leave all this [__]
dragon that's a hint of if anyone else
knew what I know yeah sure and that's a
bit of a she was murdered and it seems
to me you lived your life like a candle
in the wind welcome back to Buckingham
Palace fan TV although I don't think
they can use the official name they've
got against the Queen their mana Kate
did not inform winner this is not like
this is damaging this is damage for the
war family it's in fact that they didn't
involve the Queen that was that the
worst thing if it were thing yes it is
you must inform the Queen they did
inform the Queen they sent her a letter
something textbook she does not use the
phone the stupid [__] aggressive
they're doing things that they do things
their own selves and not on the colossi
could be divorced in the future every
scenario they could divorce at some
point have you ever heard of Henry the
eighth he's the type of guy who when the
Queen inevitably dies at the ripe old
age of warning yeah I only wish I could
join her down there she's definitely on
to hell he's overwhelmed right all them
on the kill the thing is Rory's at home
watching right now Cohen
what's granddad doing on true news he
doesn't have an organized he's not used
to his boy he's been brought into our
family she's old she did it all during
life all alive she can become an actress
any time this this is coming down show
me how he could have a breakdown
[Music]
this is any food reviewer Harry could
have a breakdown no he's the clearest
thinker
this guy's thank you in the rough these
[__] murdered my mother I'm off
and now is the time you might have a
breakdown when he goes I'm good I might
leave the royal family I won't want to
take any more more your money people go
you Armenti he might have a breakdown if
it's like what we noticed a crisis we've
noticed for that year he's one of those
people who hangs on to other people's
lives to forget about his orders what
makes you think that because he's got a
50 year old badge of the Queen his head
Annie I think he's actually wearing and
I don't even know where you'd source
this a Union Jack flag the thing is when
the Union Jack hoodie is in flag Brian
is Union Flag is only the jacket safety
is doubled up with the her underneath is
like just in case I got too hot becomes
t-shirt I need it on the t-shirt as well
just in case just in case yeah let's
hear more from this stable character
they're not telling the people what's
going on we know I know what's happening
people are shocked even Nicks is which
always disappointed Nicholas Mitchell is
the BBC royal correspondent even
Nicholas whitshire was disappointed oh
my god if you manage this point Nicholas
which oh what a life is look I guarantee
he's got a TV set he's definitely got
Kyle named after the Royal finger and he
looks after all the cats on the street
yeah yeah we want you back here you know
with the woth I mean sporting the war
famine sporting the people the public
they had enough fun Harry was always a
bit of a three-finger from every little
indie kids little interview system it's
where you can there was a time I seen
him in the army and he was sort of
having a bit of a joke with the lads and
there's a little clip of him sort of
taking the piss out his grandmother a
bit Oh granny wouldn't like that you
know he was making a joke about it but
he always came across as the one who
would be like you know is this [__]
isn't for me Epstein from one conspiracy
to another well I suppose in many ways
Brian the good link here is a good
friend of Prince Andrew for many years
and a trusted confidant Jeffrey Epstein
sadly passed away by causes that we
aren't currently fully aware of I've
gotta be honest I've got a theory
yeah but I think a lot of people's
theories are off Brian that man my
theory I fix suicide by one suicide so
they've looked at Epstein's dead body
yeah all right wow you really don't
mention woods this is a horrible [__]
penal contest know that yet Brian this
man killed himself please that's pretty
obvious it wasn't a suicide it was
definitely a murder I mean I know a lot
of people are saying this because you
know they're saying he had a lot of dirt
on people so clearly it would have been
a murder but looking at his dead body
it's obvious so the theory was that
erupt the lord of bedsheets together and
then hung himself
Yeah right well a bedsheet you know it's
thick is Airy and especially when you
have to roll it together it's something
you've got to get your whole hand round
with whole thing right so it would leave
like a mark that would be very very very
thick very almost couldn't put it right
exactly exactly that is the mark that
has been left around his neck that the
mark I'm showing Lawrence of you if you
could google it is very thin like a cord
like an electrical cord that is being
pulled very very tight now it's being
pulled so tight that it's cut his neck
it's actually cut through the skin and
left bloody marks on his neck there was
no blood found on the bed sheets the bed
sheets would have taken his way on the
wooden of left a very clear thin line
like indented into his neck and also
according there were a lot of people
experts in this field that the body
weight that would have basically been
what killed him from hanging would have
not fractured his neck especially not as
many times as his neck was fractured
he's Faction his neck a lot in his life
yeah well before he died it's just
really super clear this was a deep thin
bloody mark not a thick mark that was
left by Benji it was a thin bloody more
probably an electrical cord extreme
pressure no blood on the bed sheets as
I've just said yeah and yeah clearly a
mirror and so much saw the first
responders who were supposed to preserve
the crime scene not touch anything
especially not move anything yeah first
thing they did
moved everything got him out with a
[__] all of evidence up I think they
went oops silly yeah let's get you all
cleaned out and basically made it
impossible forensics to actually do the
test that they would normally have done
so that's that then murder not a suicide
you know I still maintain Brian killed
himself
you narrow-minded man I'll tell you who
else is pregnant confirming 2019 to be
one of the worst years of my life
yeah it's Crowe Lawrence oh really yes
great wave it off it's all about all
over the DRAM guys no I mean in many
ways Brian this woman would have been
perfect for you like look at her like
you love arms like that see there she is
with a little she's a mother know that
we got a respect that you know I mean
god bless her I wish our best to look
her in a room I wish you the breasts the
best of luck everybody and all of that
hope it goes well where's the baby daddy
that's my question
look there is fair sale wasn't a tight
she made him a red velvet cake one day
on Instagram and I was just like Sky's
living everything I felt like doing in
the 80s you taken everything I worked
for a [__] yeah you know like
imma fight your [__] ass are you
gonna fight him I'd fight them to the
death for why not to the death strip to
the west yeah I don't think that would
be a good look for you so you you know
you got the girl you won yeah
we live to fight another day all I will
say you know if it doesn't work out I'd
be a good step tart this isn't what's
goin on yeah I think she just gets her
like Bo do a lot you know there's a lot
of men who watch her
Brian why is she getting her bum oh I
didn't know these channels existed where
people just get their bodies out all the
time are you playing ignorant sort of
put me off a little bit had no idea
until I like you I love you you're so
cute so sexy and so so hot
thanks for all that happiness yeah damn
Adele talk about looking absolutely
smoking hot and sexy for sure babe
stunning all these men think they're the
one who's in with the charms like you
know anything to see this comment and go
I actually uploaded a day ago this one
is numbered 4060 I didn't expect that
I'm gonna go down this Avenue I hope you
come with me it's not the [__] that
she's a bigger lady it's the [__] that
she's embossing this ring stuff now
which it isn't
sighs thing obviously she does not look
like someone who does any exercise it's
it's not her brand it's like me coming
out with a [__] like a cardio workout
yeah it's just obviously not what I'm
about let me go no tough workout oh
you'd literally be better off just going
up some stairs indulgence she's lost
more calories going to Aldi to get the
thing and then I'm packaging it little
evolutive machine yes
I didn't realize why people sent me this
but now I'm slowly realizing that they
think it's a 1l tree it's a white
channel it's a sort of legal
masturbation sort of thing yeah for guys
who love bigger women you know I love
pick a woman a slightly different shape
I've got to admit what still I get it
it's just a bit weird because there are
porn sites bro why watch her funny on
with some really [__] exercise now but
you can just get on and type bbw on
pornhub just devil's advocate of them
present devil's advocate Brian some
people don't like pornography some
people want to get to know a woman they
think it's sexy you know it's weird you
know oh I'm in the bedroom with it I'm
Carl I'm holding the camera but why I
think is weird is the guy who is
watching a bbw woman getting gangbanged
on a porn site should be the weirdo yeah
no he's the normal guy yeah the one who
wants to watch her exercise and get to
know her and all of that and the one who
wants to obsessively watch her over and
over and over again and know her
favorite color and all that but that's
the weird avoid him yeah not the one who
likes the porn and especially in skies
in this comments weird all right he's
back the legend one of the men who
really made true news what it is food
reviewer I do reviews on the YouTube you
never knew such a cool dude I keep it so
flat and do you know why it's because I
know whether to buy that food these bar
is bad
do you see any difference still sleepy
still got the same hair roughly the same
face just a cuddly goes and I love him
all right guys
from the store or back from the hiatus
we're gonna be making some chicken parm
right now do you think you lost his love
for food review a little yeah I feel
like sometimes you can get all reviewed
out you know we do I think what happened
honestly I think when you're at the top
of the game in North challenging you is
just like whatever
[__] what is the point yeah and I
think blue varmints come along and give
them something to worry about you're
under oh I got a reason to get my throne
yeah prove I've got the crow well in
many ways like blue van man's kind of
like the maz Vidal to food reviews
McGregor he's the wily to the Stobbs the
difference is is food reviewers far more
talented than Wylie I think that's fair
sue yeah except both of them own a Rolex
so the ingredients are pretty easy we
got the chicken canola oil for frying
breadcrumbs all-purpose flour
rigatoni if there's not a stick of
butter I'm gonna be devastated
all-purpose flour with salt pepper how
is he suddenly more from Boston this
mango be like okay
the breading station is radius on this
all-purpose flour [__] you're ready
to go buddy all right it looks like he's
been dipped in sawdust
it's it's so covered in cheese like if
he's dropping a whoops there's no need
for it to be that cheesy though surely
that's a lot yeah this is palm chicken
chicken palm that doesn't look good just
our Wynette that's a lot of cheese it
was already covered in cheese then you
just lay the chicken right on top of
that nice batter pasta maybe grate some
extra Parmesan cheese on top extra
cheese all right now that we're complete
with the chicken parm let's go ahead and
give it a try get some pasta first he's
gotten better since we seen him as a kid
yeah hmm just eating any review mmm mmm
so we've separated from we've gotta
finish the meal there are big channels
that let themselves go dormant for a
year don't get tanked heavies no
neighbors no unbelievable dude we've got
a loyal following for the scope what an
audience
again every situation now it's as if
we've divorced him and he just wants to
have a meeting like the court he always
does about three or four bites yeah he
delivers any review yeah anything and
that's why we appreciate it
another one wow he's actually fuming at
this point love the fact that so many
times though in general youtubers feel
the need to fill the air with just ba ba
ba ba ba ba just to keep the things go
he doesn't give a [__] that we're in his
house exactly and he's not here to
entertain you you're wanting quality
review this is what you're gonna get you
know he's not just gonna give that up to
you in the first 60 seconds now you
gotta wait for that good stuff and
here's what don't [__] with cats taught
me you can learn so much about a person
just by looking what's in the frame oh
yeah so we're seeing sort of a beaten-up
wheel it seems like quite an old car you
definitely had a good time in that comp
that's it yeah eating like I love that
his eye movement while he's eating it
it's like you know when you say in the
matrix where they've plugged the thing
in the back of their head and you see
the eye fluttering yeah it's it's like
he's downloading the data he's putting
all the thoughts together yeah he isn't
some guy who just comes up with random
[__] this is all considered yeah this is
like is that cumin it is cumin yeah he's
having an inside conversation yeah I
would love to hear him talk mo yeah so I
couldn't know all these little thoughts
but I humbly appreciate the way we also
feel almost like privileged to witness
this anyway so yeah exactly you you you
don't just expect sort of someone to
turn up with that level of qualification
isn't just deliver knowledge like this
is taking two decades minimum Decatur
the level he's on yeah it's you know you
don't go to a martial artist and expect
their become a black belt day one that's
it we're white bolts yeah this guy is a
black belt we got to respect that and we
gotta wait for that knowledge to be
passed on I'd say you're more of a blue
belt oh I'd like to get my brown belt
yeah so yes that was food reviewer if
you have never met him before he does
reviews on the YouTube you know check
him out he's a good kid
his cough yeah classic yeah I mean ice
is still class that was golden era we're
gonna keep watching in the future
episodes of true news if you enjoyed the
series last year
we are back [__] don't forget to like
the video subscribe thanks for watching
I'm seriously